hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
so over the last week me and my mate
James have been playing a cooperative
horror game called The Blackout Club
have you heard of it
the premise is quite unique we play as
teenagers trying to understand the
paranormal things going on at night in
our neighborhood
the adults are sleepwalking and there's
a mysterious shape trying to murder us
and wait there's more the best bit that
shaped monster can only be seen when we
close our eyes first we play the game
and get a little scared then we try to
break the game by throwing adults off of
cliffs like you do but then something
happened which honestly is one of the
scariest things I've ever experienced so
I put that into I hope you enjoy it I'll
shut up let's get on with this we are
friends how do you do that kids nowadays
write house phone again on I'm blinkin
up on the d-pad up on the deeper yeah
right top left window someone just just
jumped off a bed top left window middle
window now middle window that's it I
guess if I can see him I can see him Oh
Deary me is he going is it we can be
move him that's what we'll do well the
absolutely boss rush you know you taste
Ellen on prosper
aha let me try this out come here come
with me okay I can taste you good that's
what happens you join pinenut Studios
there at Rhodes oh my god there's
someone across the street there's a man
right what we'll do what we'll do I'll
kick this door and we'll just run like
hell one run like hell really okay oh my
god it's 3:00 the minister even right
behind you right
but we could have used it I just thought
I'd be fun to just kick a door in so I
try and shoot with a crossbow going on I
see this they see this let me go to your
left to your left to your left to your
left to your left okay where are you I'm
coming I'm coming up I need to get on
mission right okay so okay top
right-hand side address 9:50 I'm just
looking at you grind now okay right
we've got to record evidence in this
house okay
I'm my noses up your ass to give you an
idea of how close I am this is my kind
of thing we can't close the store
anymore I wonder why all right because I
kicked it off its hinges get to be the
a-team every day right I have no idea
what kind of evidence we need he's a
skateboarder though check out this check
out this sexy [ __ ] oh hell yeah have
you ever seen never seen home alone
I have always watched that every
Christmas in my entire leg well what if
we became the blackout club's Wet
Bandits and we just turn the taps on
every to everywhere we went
I am down with that I'm gonna whilst you
sat on it oh look we're waking people up
oh no oh no we're making noise we
shouldn't have been the Wet Bandits I'm
sorry
the new improved Wet Bandits two teenage
girls who turned the taps of the White
House they got scared
let's go down this little shaft in fact
how would you say that in your Londoner
accent she would it be shopping a shaft
so you've been shafted
did you see that even old baby that
noise
Oh God is here I'm running I'll grab my
own leg is he's not going well
okay I'm gonna chase her I broke my leg
as well
okay I'm hiding I'm hiding I don't know
what's behind us
oh there's one right in front of you be
careful eyes coming you stinking there's
one right behind you
yeah it's chase enews chase the guy was
invisible he's chasing you
he is absolutely chasing me you're right
I don't know what to do I think I think
I'm a goner there are icons that keep
yourself alive
okay okay I'm gonna try and finish the
mission I have to continue without your
sacrifice
the shame like these forgotten if I can
get to you know you run away and tell
people my mind my mind does not my own
this is doing stuff I'm coming for you
I am I'm reviving you but the guys
chasing me so we're just running
straight up here go bridge bridge bridge
he's alright he's not here he's not here
right we're in number 918 so we're the
one next door I'm done showing off the
gift of dance up here on the top of what
the gifted white your thoughts dolls
I love your accent I can't wake you up
tase you in the face
come on of love I'm gonna record her
let's just film up
yeah just keep an eye out for that
visible what are you doing image I'm
having this yeah
I get it we're looking for evidence of
ask a bit excavation where is he I was
in the house right next to us is in the
house right next to us
yes yeah Pete's going around he's at the
street side of the house tell me if he's
in the house I'm gonna go hide I think
he's coming he's coming in yeah he's in
on the ground floor right now what kind
of noise is that away where is he
God really is he found me it's all red
Rami please don't say your phone it's
right next to me dude I can smell his
testicles is that close really close to
you you keep screwing up than standing
next to you doing a circle and then go
back down I'm in a wardrobe I know
what's EcoPlus what's that called in
America closet closet I'm in the closet
Jamie I'm in the closets right no rush
to come out it's 2019 I've been here
four years she's gonna keep me where
were you conceived he comes down here I
am absolutely buggered okay you need to
up here for now it's well strange
looking down cuz I can just see you
crowd talking like 30 meters in the
catacombs
exactly
and I can there is bulletproof oh I need
a lockpick god damnit no I might have
one yeah I could kick it open running
then run around like an idiot no what if
I kept I'm gonna try that I'm gonna try
this this in camera pisses off alright
that definitely needs wait you kick it
off but it's okay you can kick it I
found the phone on the phone on the
phone I'm scared
oh wait where's the exit well we started
isn't it Shrek and you can hit a 360
whilst jumping Dragster what a guy
can you please turn out so I can steal
off your ass thank you I think these
ones are blind are you trying to get
close enough stop making noise I am
gonna regret this but I'm gonna hide
here and hope they walk as fast and I
can't walk it okay walk it that's a good
word
Oh
right Dragster open the door and I
managed to pickpocket whilst it happened
oh my word this is this is a beast I've
got a massive cornet oh oh okay don't
make me hungry
it's in the bin okay I'll record the bin
see eggs if I did we actually
successfully do a mission you're kidding
race you back dude don't you see on the
map oh this is bliss why don't we get
this mission first time around right I'm
kicking this dog and then I'm running
you ready everybody around this dog
before I kick it in they'll be funny can
you see me where is she yeah she's
jumped oh she's the other fence
what would Jesus do the gift of dance
[Laughter]
[Music]
I'm just gonna take it out she's on the
roof she's on the roof be careful
it's definitely not in that basement
filmed it go go go go go
grab her up grab the things come into
things coming oh god oh god oh god just
get back to the start
get out of it I'm wounded it's worth it
it's worth it just get back to the stop
what's this through six 360 though maybe
this week 360 go Tony Bogues prosecuted
nightclub nightclub your I would totally
play Tony Hawk's Pro Skater nightclub
manager game exclusively for skaters
trip wire just in case let's go get
wanted you walk into it oh I should have
put it down here actually we should put
down up there I've got one I've got some
others oh god this one right here all I
want to see this frame of the clip
ready gone rock bottom all the way off
go Jamie we need to dance after that
I like how the other two even though we
finish the mission master
[Music]
okay understood
[Music]
[Music]
I'm done with this one it's not
necrophilia the game you know I'm good
I'm gonna jump off the cliff with her
let me know how it goes
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah I'm still filming much Vito I need
to get away from nothing
yeah we do trip my trip man here let's
try and get him oh wow I've jumped yeah
we do he's coming he is coming
so you see him stop dinner no I can't
see anything I want to go back up I'm
gonna go back up I can hear something
he's walking he's back up what do you
think boat boat boom and dragster are
thinking right now
well he keeps talking so I think he's
had enough got to write a review about
this tomorrow but my editor expects it's
on his desk first thing already
what is that noise you hear that yeah
there's some man talking can you hear me
oh my god he said my name he said Adam
aru no he said Adam aru what that fake
he said my name what is going on this is
awesome
Neil this is nearly done Neil I'm gonna
do what he says anyone who's awesome
I don't what was you know hear this I
can that's why I'm worried
but for allegiances at the morning I
want you to think about where your
strength lies and where the strength of
your friends I am scared hopeless right
now what you really say your name she
said my name about six times now
and he said it right no one says my name
this is brilliant what we just witnessed
I'm okay let's Hey doo-doo-doo-doo
[Music]